hello everybody and welcome to this
evening's online weezener gallery tour
my name is shannon rose mcauliffe and i
am the manager of the student arts
programs here at mit
i'm joined by sarah herzl who is the
coordinator of the wiesner student art
gallery
and nancy diane valladares who is an
interdisciplinary artist from
tegucigalpa honduras
nancy earned her bfa from the school of
the art institute of chicago
and is a 2020 graduate of mit's program
in arts culture and technology
nancy's project this evening was
supported by act
by a fianco fellowship through mit's
transmedia storytelling initiative
by the film study center at harvard and
our very own council for the arts at mit
after a brief introduction by sarah
about the exhibition
nancy will lead us through the virtual
show via her screen share
you're also welcome to view the
exhibition on the webpage which
we are putting into the chat below
after the tour please join us for some
question and answer session with nancy
you can feel free to submit your
questions using the chat box you can use
the raise hand feature or
likewise you could unmute or come on
camera so that we can enjoy some
really lively and engaging discussion
together um
final order of business please note that
this event is being recorded
and may be made publicly available on
the wiesner gallery website
or elsewhere in the future if you do not
wish
to appear in this recording please take
a moment to make sure that your video
and audio are muted and turned off
during the event
and if you have any questions about this
please contact sarah herzl
at s herzl mit.edu
with any questions or concerns so before
we turn it over to nancy
my dear colleague sarah has a few words
thank you shannon rose hi um
i'm sarah herzl i am really excited to
see everyone here today
it's been a really great pleasure
working with nancy
i would like to extend my thanks also to
sophie laloy
her graphic design collaborator and a
special thanks to heidi erickson our
graphic designer
for mit's office of the arts it takes
a collaboration such as these to animate
the vision
of artists like nancy and i'm very
grateful for everyone's participation
botanical ghosts is a multi-part
exploration
of the history buried in the soil of
tayla honduras
nancy viaduras uses her website to
transport us
to a ghostly place where the earth
itself
holds dark secrets of colonialism
and power the plants in this place and
the bodies
buried under the soil call to us
and especially to nancy to tell their
story
nancy's vision makes poetry of the link
between human domination and
environmental ruin her deep quality of
perception
links the present to many layers of the
past
the heart to the scientific mind and
human bodies to the biology of the earth
that holds us
nancy makes potent use of research-based
artwork
and illuminates the importance of
emotion
to tell stories both historical
and scientific i'm very pleased to
introduce
nancy viadoras
thank you so much sarah for the
introduction
um and to everyone who you know is here
and made this possible my collaborators
um
to say thank you one more time and to
ease our gallery for all their support
um and uh yeah for the opportunity to
you know once
again gather even though we're in a
moment where that's not possible
um but i'm really really happy to see
everyone and a lot of loved ones and
and colleagues here as well um but
uh yeah i feel you know uh thank you
shannon
for the introduction um
and uh i wanted to just talk really
briefly about
um sort of the impetus behind uh this
project
um and uh you know sort of like a kind
of more personal
lens as to you know like where a lot of
these ideas kind of came from
um so during my time at as a student at
uh mit programming
culture and technology um i spent most
of my time doing research in this
particular site called lancidia
botanical gardens what used to be
a botanical experimental station that
was fine
found and founded in 1923 or 24
by united fruit company um and um
i first stumbled upon the story of uh
british botanist and archaeologist
dorothy popeno
in that site in 2017 i believe
um and so i spent a lot of time kind of
uh
connect making these historical uh
threads and connections
um you know trying to like really
understand
what was like buried beneath that
particular site
and i felt that that place functioned as
a monument to the legacy of
american interventionism in the region
and it was a nexus of several
forces that shape honduran political
ecologies and biospheres
for decades to come and um so dorothy
popeno as a character
um you really felt her presence in the
gardens
you do still to these days um you know
she
uh hunts visitors with her almost
biblical demise and the story of how she
perished
which was um uh eating a fruit of the
aki which is
this you know fruit that you see here in
the background
it was and it was a very little was
actually written about her work
um in the site even though she did a lot
of
really great contributions um and she
was a great scholar
archaeologist and botanist in her own
right but it was sort of hidden behind
the larger narrative um and her husband
was involved in his career as a botanist
um
and um i wanted to first as an
introduction i'm gonna start
uh sharing my screen
and i would like to share an excerpt of
the film as a to serve as an
introduction
[Music]
you
i still do not know whose ghost you hope
to become
in your letters to your sister you write
about all the things you did for love
and out of love
i read them and reread them until the
meaning of words dissolved and your
handwriting became a cipher
for recovering all the things we had
forgotten
in my roundabout pursuit of you i found
myself haunted by your words
by the things that we never recorded or
documented but whose absence we clearly
felt
i asked you once if you thought that
soil contained memories
you answered if it could remember then
we would eat all the lifetimes it had
consumed
in your time at kew gardens you often
talked about freedom
your inquisitive mind your belly streak
always got you into trouble
i remember because i often felt you left
me out on purpose
like the things we had shared moved to a
quiet murmur in the background
and only the object of your current
obsession could ever draw your attention
at any given time
[Music]
so
[Music]
something
[Music]
what things should be unearthed what
should be allowed to rest
beneath the ground what do we preserve
if the soil remembers why do we need
today taxonomize and catalog
i'm gonna pause the the video there you
can watch the rest of the short um
in the in the site um it's available
there
and i'm just gonna sort of um
give you guys a little bit more of a
background into some of this
um material and then go through
a walkthrough of the site so we can kind
of experience it together
um
so um when i returned to pope in a house
for the second time
in 2018 i sat near popeno house and
watched a group of bees perform a
beautiful dance around yellow hibiscus
dilapidated and in disrepair the wooden
building murmured all the things
rendered by now by history
i felt the same weight that often
accompanies monuments to violence
settle like a blanket on my shoulders
not too far from pope in a house
surrounded by a fence and dotted with
several danger signs
lanza dia houses two specimens of
plasapita
or known also known as the akitri which
produces a pear-like fruit that if is
eaten before it ripens or is improperly
cooked
induces a severe hypoglycemia or known
as jamaican
vomiting sickness and from what we know
and read in several books it's in
biographical notes dorothy popeno died
in 19
in december 1932 after eating improperly
cooked
aki um
i spent quite some time weaving
dorothy's life and her work with the
transatlantic voyage of the aki
whose migration reveals the ongoing
extraction of human labor and resources
at the service of empire
this fruit crossed through the middle
passage from west africa and made its
way to several islands in the caribbean
specifically jamaica
where it became a staple food in the
cooking of the region
and eventually eventually it made its
way
to lens city as part of experiments and
propagation of tropical species for
united fruit company
um and as i was doing my research going
through several different
archives and and sources i it was clear
to me that a narrative was forming from
all these missing pieces and their
deliberate silences and
uh political occlusions and i was
drawing from collections at harvard
peabody museum
hunt institute for botanical
documentation at carnegie mellon
university
um at the royal kew gardens among others
where i sought to create a new
speculative archive called
a dedicated mechanism or forgetting
which um
contains a collection of letters
documents and images that were compiled
over the period of two years
that i was working on botanical ghosts
um so now i'm going to sort of
go ahead and give us very
brief tour of the website experience um
so that uh you know you all can
go after the talk and experience it on
your own
and um once again i wanted to thank my
collaborator
and dear friend sophie laloy who worked
for a long time
uh and um to make this happen i would
not have been able to do this without
her
um and so the way that the
website is structured is sort of like
uh a book uh several chapters
you know like kind of comprise this
particular
uh web iteration of the project um so
you're able to sort of experience the
film
and then also enter the archive where a
lot of the documents and images
are kind of housed and
[Music]
the archive is still living and it's
ongoing
um and uh more things are being added so
please check back
often um to see you know what's new so i
can kind of show you what that looks
like
and then the archive is interactive
which means that
like you know things can be kind of
reconfigured
um and rearranged and uh they can be
um uh you know coded in different ways
um and you know different relationships
that kind of emerge from them
um and these uh are kind of sourced from
um some of the artifacts for example the
dorothy popeno
unearthed while she was doing
work at lansitia some of these
are film stills um some of these are
some sort of letter fiction letter
exchanges letters that i wrote to
dorothy um
as well as some of the photographs that
she took while she was at
um at lanzatia and um
yeah it's uh for now um you know the
archive is still growing but
i'm looking forward very much to putting
you know like more of the material
um that's on there um and so please you
know go ahead and
play with it and experience it it's
meant to
be experienced more as a photo album
or um a little bit more intimately
um than you know traditional sort of
like archival like form
um and so
uh yeah i'm gonna kind of go back
um the rest of the website is sort of
comprised of a series of writings and
fictions
um you know the kind of tell
of um you know about like sort of like
dorothy's experience at la satia
and i wanted to sort of read a brief
excerpt
from one of the pieces of writing
i was buried near the palmariums the
valley of lanzitia had been cultivated
and engineered for hundreds of years
before we arrived
before the people who lived here had
even settled it
let me tell you about the worlds within
worlds that came from lansidia
this has always been a place of death
where bodies were fed to the soil and
then proceed to becoming and
transforming
in order to ensure the formation of the
acres upon acres
upon plantations in the coast of
honduras we chose to accept the death of
many things
in the soggy marsh of the plantation
everything makes love
everything consumes everything then it
returns and releases
to summon the specters that are buried
in the marshlands in the jungle
requires an act of necromancy and magic
a spectre is that which leaves behind an
imprint whose frequency cannot be sensed
with tools for quantification
rather it requires a sensibility to
speak to the inanimate and the dead
and the living things that are
considered dead but aren't aren't
and the persons whose intimacy has been
obscured and undermined by structures of
power and dispossession
to accommodate for the world we were
about to build we burned a billion
graves
leveled raised to the ground cemeteries
within cemeteries of microbial
subjectivities and vegetal life
ecological networks that must now parlay
an imbalance in the systems that have
been disrupted
the things that once slept now have
awakened whose life do we choose
choose to learn and whose deaths do we
do we then memorialize
um and so um you can sort of experience
this
as a sort of web version of the text you
can kind of go through and it's
not in any particular chronological
order um but
it's rather more of a collaging of
narratives and and temporalities
um and finally as part of um
you know these sort of fictional
exchanges that i had with dorothy
i spent some time uh writing letters to
her
over a period of two years and i felt
that i
sort of like had an experience with her
that
was a you know across time um and i
wanted to read to you one of the letters
that um
i wrote to her um during my time
doing research um
i'm gonna read it out a lot now
dear dorothy it's strange to be writing
to you right now
and 2020 to express wonder at the
various interests and desires we share
despite being cultivated under different
worlds
i recently visited peabody museum which
houses the collection of your
photographs and artifacts that you
excavated from lansidia
i finished my student here in cambridge
massachusetts i think of the places you
frequented here
and the institutions that across time
marked both of our lives
what is the likelihood that i would find
you here as well
i wanted to share with you a bit of my
family history and my motivations behind
writing to a ghost
as a child mornings in my house were
marked by rituals of death
although nowhere no one ever explicitly
told me
they were so the cracking open of
windows the rituals around the cutting
of hair
the portents of the animals and the
blooming of rare flowers that were
marked with a pencil on a
kitchen calendar
when it rained we remembered the smell
of patrick were served as both
balm and a wound a reminder of the
circumstances which brought us to other
shores and other seas
it's hard sometimes to imagine ourselves
as young as we were
living in that house the one that is no
longer home
we still remember the cliffs and the
hideouts memories
of a childhood's worth of mapping the
proximate and the familiar
tiny taxonomies of rocks shells and
leaves
here is a favorite tree these are the
best branches to pick mangoes and that
is the best time to hear the song of the
luminous bird
we learned from our grandmothers to read
the paths of the insects
and the white moths that are in moss on
the guava tree
we knew that april rain brings a blanket
of insects that crawl inside our ear
and the migrant ants whose yearly visits
invited the winds
the moth my grandmother's favorite
prophet would often visit
with the same missive to announce the
coming of an ending
our family cursed with the gift of long
life spans was deeply intimate with a
kind of mourning that
has nothing to do with burials
only now do i realize how so many of our
daily rituals were colored by the
remnants of the non-living
it's here at the crossing of these
thresholds that the world of the dead
folds into my own
and so you see dear dorothy at certain
times of day we're not so far from each
other
sometimes as if you're i feel as if
you're sitting like
i feel as if you're sitting next to me
until next time
and um you know this concludes sort of
my
little brief tour of the website and the
web experience of this project
um and i think yeah i
if anyone has any questions i don't know
sarah
what's next but oh i will chime back in
thank you so much
that was fantastic and really compelling
and i'm sure i have questions
i hope other people do so at this point
um i would love to invite people either
to put questions in the chat
raise your hand or if you'd like to
unmute come on audio or video we'd also
welcome your conversation
yeah anyone who wants to come on video
we welcome you just to help celebrate
nancy
and her exhibition
well i've got a question that if uh
other people are still sort of
um letting all of this marinade in their
brains there's a lot to take in because
it was so impressive so
um what i would love to know a little
bit more what's your personal history
with the lancethia research station
like did you find it and then were you
inspired to tell the story
or were you first looking to tell the
story and then you discovered the
station
and discovered dorothy popeno do you
have a history in taylor sort of tell us
some more of this back story
i actually um kind of stumbled upon it
it it this is sort of
uh a place or it's become
a park where you can kind of go visit
and um
you know sort of um you know it's
it's a place where you kind of like go
go to in the north coast i honestly
didn't know much about it
until i went there once with a cousin of
mine
and um i was very very
uh just compelled by you know a lot of
things
um in that site it was very very left an
impression in me
um and the more research that i did um
the
you know the deeper kind of like you go
into a story i realized actually
um there's there was like a lot of
connections um to our history uh that i
didn't really
really realize until much later for
example my grandfather
like he worked on you know he was a
laborer who worked on the
railroads um that would you know were
used to kind of transport
um you know fruit and materials
uh in the north coast and um
it's a very common uh history actually
in honduras family kind of history in
honduras where
you probably had some
family member worked either
implantations or
you know in sort of like in some kind of
agriculture
and um and i think i think that that
um was sort of a part of also the
imaginary i think of honduran cultural
identity
um it which you know
it's a sort of like a fact of
strange kind of shame but simultaneous
pride that honduras was called the first
banana republic in the sort of
pejorative term
um those used to describe you know
countries in
central america and latin america whose
soils and territories were used you know
for
um essentially a kind of extractive
agricultural paradigm
and so um it's it's both
personal but um also like a very um
not uncommon um sort of common
experience i think in
in honduras and other places in central
america as well
that's excellent um really good answer
um that leads me to some other questions
i see that we've got a question from
joshi
well thanks hi nancy
uh congratulations thank you i had a
question about um
dorothy's politics as the wife of
somebody employed by the united food
company um
to what extent did she was there any
criticality about
kind of their position and his being
there
or was it more just focused on
um her work i'm yeah i'm curious about
how
maybe was there any tension between
between them or perhaps
um even yeah between him and sort of his
role in in public or as an official role
or a private
difference there yeah that's a great
that's a great question
um so uh there's a couple i think
there's a kind of couple
a couple of things in there um that i'll
try to try to answer
um so in terms of uh
dorothy's politics i think um i mean i
mean i can only kind of like speculate
at this point
um although i did spend some time with
her um sort of letters and
her writing um and i do believe that
there was some tension
uh of course between her sort of
um attempt at being
um you know a botanist an archaeologist
a school a scholar in her own right
particularly at that time and sort of
like maybe
making and paving her way um you know
despite the fact that
she was often in the shadow of of of
wilson
you know wilson popeno's kind of big
name
um i i think that um
my relation personally my relationship
to her is a very complicated one i
really deeply believe that she was
um uh complicit in all of these kind of
structures
um she very much performed the labor of
um i think uh empire you know cap
of capitalism of um you know these kind
of colonial desires to collect
to you know to you know preserve and
then you know to
museu you know of like uh
you know historicizing you know things
perhaps that
don't necessarily need to be
historicized or par perhaps they do i
don't know
um so
i think it was com complicated because
she also had a very
i think a way of thinking about life um
and uh about you know the creatures you
know the
the plants the vegetal world that she
was encountering and that place
i think that she was also
i i think that she was thinking about
animacy
um in uh you know at a time where it was
like very precocious thinking i think
um but i cannot of course project you
know these
more contemporary notions of what that
means particularly under
the post humanities you know um and so i
think it's it's complicated i think
in many ways it's excavating those
questions in those silences
where fiction kind of comes in um
and so i think the dorothy popeno that
i'm kind of dealing with here is a
fiction
um she is very much a character
uh that i've appropriated um in a way
and so
my i feel my job as an artist i think it
was here to
you know to kind of harness that in a
way that
was productive maybe or i hope was
productive
answer the
looks like we've also got a couple of
really lovely questions in the chat so
in case some can't see
i will read uh the first one from
samuel artists are often driven by
intuition and motives that can be
difficult to verbalize
you talked about the impression that the
park had on you
can you talk more about that what was
the attraction
before you had done all of this research
and processing
and what do you think you were seeking
through this undertaking and this
process
uh yeah thank you sam for that question
um i
that's you know i don't know if um
i think intuition is a good word uh i i
think
this is uh that particular site was a
place that i
i felt contained already you know you
just walk in there you just know that
there's
um you know things that are haunting
that place it just
it just feels like it's a place that has
a lot of
stories to tell um
i think i had a kind of emotional
experience there as well because
the north coast of honduras has become
um i i don't know and i can't give you
exactly percentages or
or or numbers right now off the top of
my head but uh has
the ecologies in the biome of that area
has been
largely uh turn into
one big plantation you know palm upon
like a palm plantation
um sort of monocultural
landscape and uh lanzatia sort of
is this oasis that um
has incredible you know biodiversity
that's both engineered um
but native um so it's it's sort of like
a little protected area that still
contains the specters of
like what the ecosystem was before and
then how it was transformed through the
introduction of all these new
plant species into the region um and i
think that that to me
was that to me was sort of like
maybe the thing that the the first
magnet
um and then it just kind of became a
little warm
wormhole that i couldn't escape for like
two years and still trying to escape
um but um
i think that uh in terms of what i was
seeking through undertaking the process
i think i was looking for a story as
well
and i kind of stumbled upon it and i
found it
and i i've kind of it's been in my mind
for a long time
um and so
uh yeah i don't know sometimes you just
kind of stumble upon those things these
things can be inexplicable in the best
possible way
um so christiana says
uh there's gratitude for the beautiful
presentation in the website
um and an appreciation
for the notes you have whose life do we
choose to mourn
whose deaths do we then memorialize and
the question
is why is the format of the archive
important to you
or important to this project
specifically it seems as though
the legacy of the archive privileges
certain items that are deemed
valuable with the significant absence of
others
and your project is very articulate in
the specter
uh from this place of absence so do you
wish to take a position
in relation to the archive uh regarding
reclaiming it
criticizing it etc
uh yeah thank you so much for that
question that's um
i definitely i mean my hope my
aspiration
is to yes to kind of uh
look at the archive is the kind of form
that definitely
needs to be um or an attempt at being
sort of uh you know critically
fabulating it you know to use the term
um uh
yeah sorry i'm like getting tongue tied
here
um i mean i think archives are
you know these uh you know forms that
kind of like
sort of seek to like re you know frame
or to
to present a certain version of a
dominant narrative
and i think that for me um
i was i was very much
interested in these kind of like empty
spaces
sort of that you pointed out um
i guess that can be filled in through
um fiction and speculation um and i
think that that is a
an act of reclamation for me um i i
think i'm still trying to work through
that
i don't know that necessarily it's it's
um that is fully
fully um fleshed out or resolved but i
my hope is that in in this
in this space and by further engaging
with it i can reach that
um but yeah i definitely feel you know
the archive has been formulated and
reformulated in so many ways
i think in you know art you know art
practices
um i was actually talking about this
with a
with sarah the other day um
uh you know i was thinking about uh
also the relationship to the family
album you know sort of like the more
personal
um you know and intimate
archives that we all sort of built as as
ways of experiencing and memorializing
the world um also as a kind of counter
narrative to this
you know more institutional and almost
hegemonic
form of telling history and so um
dorothy's
personal album a lot of those images you
know that are kind of part
in the film are drawing from her
personal
um you know sort of like more intimate
moments
you know between her family herself you
know um you know portraits of her loved
ones and i thought
that those kind of served as a weight
that the things in the archive
uh and other archives did not contain um
and that
that collusion between her more academic
um and uh
yeah more sort of like historically you
know heavy work
i think those two things were doing
something more for me
so we've got another one that uh
definitely resonates with me
can you talk a little bit more about the
aki fruit uh
its role in your relationship with
dorothy and
its history in the botanical project of
imperial expansion
i think you're right um yeah so that is
like what a network that like
needs to be traced but i'm gonna do my
best to do that
um yeah so the the aki fruit
uh became also like a really interesting
character
um for me that took on
a life of its own um i think that
definitely
uh there is part of the challenge
you know i think of this story and about
like you know these characters
particularly non-human characters
um you know is how do you
kind of try to look at history from the
perspective of
um a fruit
um that is very much an anthropolog like
anthropocentric and probably
anthropomorphic desire um but uh
ray who's the question like ray who's
the person who asked the question
my colleague um you know you yourself
talk about um the role i guess of like
empathy or what how can these
you know kind of anthropomorphic desires
could they become
like maybe
uh tools through which we can shift you
know this anthropocentrism
um so for me that was a question i don't
know if
the form itself was doing that but
um as an exercise in thinking was really
really useful
um in terms of my relationship with
dorothy
and the fruit um and this kind of like
triangulation that was happening
throughout history
um the fruit itself was the sort of like
more deeper history you know it was like
going much further back in time um
you know you know all the way back to
its you know roots
in west africa um and the fact that it'd
been
you know a staple staple food for a
really really long time much longer
before the colonial project even started
um and um
i think i really like this sort of like
you know triangulation
this kind of historical encounter
maybe as a as a vector through which a
story can be told in through
which history can be challenged and
reconfigured and
yeah i think the the networks of um
you know botanical exchange that were
part of
you know the colonial project um can
tell us a lot about
the histories are being um hidden now to
this day
particularly particularly you know like
history of
agriculture as they relate to um
you know resource extraction you know
through the exploitation
um black folks in latin america
and all over the caribbean and the
united states
because plantation histories um you know
that like were sort of flourishing at
the time
of slavery also made their way you know
through specific vectors into from the
caribbean
um and all throughout latin america and
so the technologies of agriculture that
we have now have their roots
as well implantation these are
plantation ecologies and that to me
is is a crucial a really crucial
um lens that uh
we had been missing for a really long
time particularly in honduran history
and so it's kind of locus and
reconfiguration
i think um
yeah it's it's
i think for me provided an elasticity
that
other more dominant perspectives of
history did not have
so then i sort of have a twofer for you
so give me a second because we have two
quite interrelated questions from semina
and marissa
so firstly you talk about your
complicated relationship with dorothy
she is a dear colleague but she's also
an agent of colonial
colonialism um can you say more about
your experience of getting to know your
home through this character
and relatedly the similar question and
thought from marissa
is in thinking about imperial expansion
it's interesting how you nancy described
your project as
appropriating dorothy you're very
deliberate with your diction so can you
elaborate on
both of these questions together
yep oh these are spicy questions
so i'm gonna try to answer that
um yeah i think
this is actually my roommate she's on
the other
asking the spicy questions thank you so
much
i am yeah
no i think like the this complicated
relationship with dorothy is also i
think
maybe a mirror of my complicated
relationship also to home
to you know to honduras it's um
i think it's it's it was also like a
very personal
and deeply like maybe solipsistic
also exercise because i was also working
through
um you know you know identity um
you know being part of a kind of
diaspora of central american you know
immigrants in
the united states um and
i think that those complicated
relationships
uh and positions
uh and politics also manifest themselves
in
in
like in me as well i think that that is
also a
a recognition that um that complexity i
think of being also also
uh happens to you know to this day to me
to other folks who might be members of
diaspora
um and so
maybe i don't know
if it's possible for me to appropriate
dorothy i don't know that
is the the the term that i would use but
um
yeah i mean i feel that
stories from the northern triangle
particularly honduras
honduras um it's really hard to
to to find them you know i think that
there's a lot of them
but i feel that they are not given um
as much uh leverage
or as much weight you know as they
should
um in some ways i think that um
the history of the region is has been
deeply submerged um because of
american intervention or some
interventionism in the region
um and it continues to to be so even
though
we have an ongoing exodus of
you know at this very moment of um
climate refugees that are fleeing the
region you know due to
ecological collapse you know through
corruption
through you know a lot of a lot of
different reasons but um
and i'm not saying that this is i'm not
trying to make
like a claim that this is a
you know reason but i'm certain that
these things can kind of be connected to
that so
hi congratulations nancy
thank you thank you so much where is
that i
have a little question that has to do
with
the archival impulse in your work as
well
building on um someone else's um
question earlier um
and the way your platform sort of
generates archives
out of archives i was wondering if you
could expand on
how you conceived um
the online platform as a space of
um you know cultural speculation because
the way i see it or the way i
read it and i've been sort of playing
around with the website since earlier
and
it's beautiful um
i sort of see it as a way to reconcile
the colonial historical weights
of your research with the
[Music]
and sort of the the semantic reading of
the archive
with uh the
properly situated historical present
so yeah i was just sort of wondering if
uh
you sort of see yourself as
you know um i've been reading lots of
health posture today so i was thinking
of
um the artists uh as archivists
versus the artist as ethnographer and if
you sort of see yourself
in this line of thought um um
and if it's a way for you to to reclaim
these difficult histories
sorry my question is a little you know
no no no it's great thank you so much
um that is a good question
uh so
you know in some ways like what i think
i like about this position is that
as an artist you can kind of embody
different roles
and uh um you're not necessarily
beholden i think to
to the forums or the i think traditions
of
you know these other disciplines um
which is up you know problematic but
it's also
in some ways a an impulse that i think
um a lot of artists kind of choose to
follow i think
um
i think that that flexibility and that
kind of nebulous gray area
between disciplines um is one that i
really
got for me was like very empowering i've
always i mean i've been someone who's
been interested in history but i'm not
historian
um and i may follow kind of some you
know
you know methodologies of research but
i'm not necessarily you know like
producing academic work i uh you know
first and foremost
like an artist and filmmaker and so
um
uh yeah i i don't know it's a great area
i don't know so
question mark
[Laughter]
it just makes me think of two words that
keep coming to mind that you've already
mentioned
in this q a which is stretch and
reconfigure
and i feel like i love the fact that
that the archive itself is stretchable
and reconfigurable
because it's like you're literally
parting
apart you know these the formerly known
like academic facts yes putting in like
your letter your photo your encounter
your feeling
and like fleshing it out but that
stretch and reconfigure i just think
that's really powerful
yeah i i i um i'm actually maybe i'm
gonna use this as a plug
for the common panel um
with um my colleague my colleague samina
um
and uh shireen hamza um i don't know
shireen's here
but we're actually going to be talking
precisely about this sort of like
about uh the experiences of artists
and historians in the archives and so
we're going to be having like that
discussion sometime in march
um because that i feel that like
uh one of the things that we were kind
of discussing together before like you
know the talk kind of
uh even happened was that there are
moments of affect that happen
while you're you know looking through
all of this material
that as academics you might not be able
to
express or even speculate on because
automatically that
disqualifies or
sometimes that you're trying to do as an
academic
um and uh so
the the question is then what happens
you know to
to the things that do like kind of
produce you know affect
what does it mean you know when you go
into an archive and you kind of break
down
uh when you have an emotional experience
um at
you know being there and witnessing um
seeing the material spoils i think of
kind of colonial um that colonial
impulse for collection for
organizing and classifying and um so
i think that that is that that that is
where a lot of the friction is happening
and and um yeah you know in conversation
with
with my colleagues i realized it's not
something that just
happens to the artist it's it's
something that
it's simply there's no space for that in
academia
um or maybe there should be and perhaps
maybe there should be like
a dedicated way of
addressing you know you know these other
things and makes
making space for them um
this oh sorry i don't want to talk over
you this is a really excellent
transition plugging your upcoming event
um so basically
i think we're gonna start to wrap
because we'll have the opportunity for
all of these uh
questions to continue as the dialogue
continues as
more thoughts and questions come up so
um i think we're going to start to
transition toward
closing at this point i want to thank
everybody who's here for attending this
evening
thank you to my co-host sarah and of
course thank you to nancy thank you to
sophie
for this fabulous showing of botanical
ghosts
um we'd like to encourage everybody to
watch the entire eight minutes of the
film and to explore the exhibition at
your leisure
and as we were just discussing we want
to invite everybody
back on tuesday march 16th
at 6 p.m for ongoing very stimulating
and sort of mind-blowing conversation
between nancy
uh and two of her scholars and
colleagues who also work
at the intersection of art biology and
the history of science
we'll have samina we'll have uh shireen
and basically uh you can register for
this event
the event is titled the loss of green
imagining vegetal worlds and you can
uh sign up for this through the wiesner
gallery website which is going to be
linked in the chat right now um so
also the wisner gallery website has
information
on other upcoming events in the gallery
including exhibition opportunities for
anybody who might be interested in that
so with that i think we're gonna round
off thank you
all so much for being here thank you
thank you and have a
fantastic evening thank you so much
nancy thank you so much thank you sir
thank you shannon rose beautiful to see
your work
thank you